first off i'd like to thank the scitec
committee for uh
giving us this award it's it's an
amazing honor i'd like to thank
james cameron and john landau for
trusting us uh
from the get-go to put these kinds of uh
headrigs out in the world i'd like to
thank uh
my mom linda and my recently passed away
father
kim derry and i'd like to thank my wife
erica uh
and kate noah and my two sons i'd like
to thank my um
wife michelle and my daughter lyanna for
always being beside me and
pushing me forward but we also have to
thank the rest of the crew at
technoprops we have a great crew with us
that has been working with us for many
many years including
michael davis and some other people that
have been at our sides like evan
brainard who has
really helped to push us forward and
helped us
create such wonderful things i'd like to
thank my
wife ann and my three wonderful kids
declan maeve and kellen
i'd like to thank the scitec committee
for recognizing this uh
engineering work at the service of the
film industry
and i dedicate this to my daughter
sophie
uh my wife and my parents thank you
you